how did if you have ever had jetlag then
you know how miserable it is when your
circadian clock is broken this clock is
so strong that even if you are placed in
total darkness
it keeps sticking and maintains a
24-hour cycle but the circadian clock
also must have some molecular basis how
does each individual cell in your body
knows what time it is
is there a clock jam or can we find
genes that are responsible for breaking
clear circadian clock and causing sleep
disorders or what are the messages that
tell the cell go to bed and wake up this
course will focus on how to find these
messages hidden within DNA I'd like you
to take a look at this encoded message
taken from Edgar Allan Poe's famous
short story the gold-bug in this story
the message tells how to find the buried
treasure of Captain Kidd now decoding
the pirate message is actually not too
difficult but when we try to understand
DNA things get trickier for example here
is a hidden message in the genome of the
bacterium that causes cholera this
hidden message tells the bacterium start
lapping ated cure genome right here but
how can we find a hidden message like
this in a genome that is millions of
nucleotide long in this class we will
start decoding the unbelievably complex
language of DNA but instead of Putin
corn a lab coat and performing
biological experiments we are going to
use a computer
after we warm up our algorithmic muscles
we will see how a computer can be used
to design algorithms that roll dice and
flip coins not to win big in a casino
but to look for hidden messages and
genomes we hope that you will join us in
this class to look for hidden messages
in the mysterious and beautiful language
of DNA although these instructors may
appear crazy they are not quite
as mad as they look dr. Pavel peb snare
is a distinguished professor of computer
science at the University of California
San Diego and a leading authority on
bioinformatics he's dressed this way
because he sometimes thinks that he's a
sheriff of bioinformatics a frontier
discipline underpinning the digital
revolution in biology and personalized
medicine dr. Phillip Campo is an
assistant professor of computer science
at Carnegie Mellon University to learn
why he is dressed this way you'll need
to take this course or read the textbook
by informatics algorithms an active
learning approach co-authored by the two
speakers